THANK YOU. THE SENATE NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER COMMITTEE
WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
MORNING. FOR THOSE MEMBERS WHO
ARE NOT HERE, WHICH IS EVERYONE
EXCEPT FOR, VICE CHAIR SATO. IF
YOU COULD COME DOWN TO ROOM
1200, WE COULD THEN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM FOR OUR HEARING. WE HAVE
EIGHT BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA,
FIVE OF WHICH ARE PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT, THESE BILLS WILL BE
HEARD AND FILED. ORDER SINCE WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM, WE'LL
PROCEED IN A SUBCOMMITTEE AT
THIS POINT, AND WE'LL ESTABLISH
QUORUM WHEN SUFFICIENT MEMBERS
ARE PRESENT. BUT FOR NOW, WE'LL
HEAR FROM OUR FIRST AUTHOR WHO
IS HERE AND PREPARED. SENATOR
DODD, YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR
RESOLUTION COR TEN. WHEN OR 1014
WHEN YOU'RE WHEN YOU'RE
PREPARED, THANK YOU. MR. CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS. COR TEN URGES THE
PRESIDENT TO USE EXISTING
AUTHORITY GRANTED BY THE
ANTIQUITIES ACT TO EXPAND
BERRYESSA SNOW MOUNTAIN NATIONAL
MONUMENT AND CONGRESS TO PASS
HOUSE BILL 1396 AND SENATE BILL
683. THESE MEASURES WOULD RENAME
WALKER RIDGE TO MOORLACH LU█N,
WHICH MEANS CONDOR RIDGE IN THE
PATWIN LANGUAGE. ADDITIONALLY,
THEY'LL ALSO PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN THE TRIBES BUREAU OF
LAND MANAGEMENT AND US FOREST
SERVICE. BY EXPANDING THIS
NATIONAL MONUMENT, WE ARE
PROTECTING SACRED. SACRED?
EXCUSE ME. TRIBAL LANDS AND
CRITICAL HABITAT FOR WILDLIFE
WHILE ALSO IMPROVING ACCESS TO
OUTDOORS AND HELPING TO
CONTRIBUTE TO CALIFORNIA'S GOAL
OF PROTECTING 30% OF LANDS AND
WATERS BY 2030. I HAVE WITH ME
HERE TODAY, HEKJA. BARDOWICK,
THE POLICY DIRECTOR AT THULIUM,
AND NICHOLAS JENSEN, SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE
PLANT SOCIETY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, WITH TWO WITNESSES, DUE TO
TIME CONSTRAINTS, REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS, YOU'LL BE
PERMITTED TWO MINUTES EACH, AND,
YOU CAN PROCEED WHENEVER YOU ARE
READY. YEP THANK YOU. SHE HAS
NOW ELECTRIC. HI. THANK YOU, AS
SENATOR DODD, I SAID, I'M
HAKIMABAD SWITCH THE POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THULIUM, AND I'M
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF SGR TEN.
DODD'S PROPOSAL TO, SUPPORT THE
ADDITION OF MOORLACH LUKE TO
BERRYESSA SNOW MOUNTAIN NATIONAL
MONUMENT. THULIUM IS A
CONSERVATION NONPROFIT WHOSE
MISSION IT IS TO ENGAGE IN
ADVOCACY AND ACTIVE STEWARDSHIP
WITH DIVERSE COMMUNITIES TO
CONSERVE, ENHANCE, RESTORE AND
ENJOY THE LANDS IN THE NORTH
INNER COASTAL RANGE. WE ARE ALSO
LOCAL LANDOWNERS. WE OWN LAND
ADJACENT TO THE MONUMENT, AND WE
DESIGN, BUILD AND MAINTAIN THE
REGION'S TRAILS, WHICH INCLUDE
TRAILS FOR OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE
ENTHUSIASTS, MOTORBIKES,
HORSEBACK RIDERS AND HIKERS.
MOORLACH LUKE IS SACRED TO THE
YOCHA DEHE WINTUN NATION, WHO IS
LEADING THE EXPANSION CAMPAIGN
ALONG WITH OTHER TRIBAL NATIONS.
THE AREA IS A, WILDLIFE CORRIDOR
FOR TULE ELK, MOUNTAIN LIONS,
AND BLACK BEARS. IT IS ALSO HOME
TO IMPERILED WILDLIFE, INCLUDING
BALD AND GOLDEN EAGLES, BADGERS,
PEREGRINE FALCONS, AND OVER 30
SPECIES OF RARE PLANTS. THE
REGION'S BIODIVERSE K¾T IS DUE
IN PART TO ITS GEOLOGY. WHICH
GIVES RISE TO UNIQUE PLANTS. THE
INCORPORATION OF MOORLACH INTO
BERRYESSA SNOW MOUNTAIN NATIONAL
MONUMENT WILL DIRECT THE BUREAU
OF LAND MANAGEMENT, WHO
CURRENTLY CONTROLS THE LAND, TO
CONTINUE TO MANAGE IN WAYS THAT
PROTECT THE ECOLOGICALLY AND
CULTURALLY SENSITIVE SITES OF
THE REGION. NØ LAND WILL BE,
TRANSFERRED OUT OF PRIVATE
PROPERTY OWNERSHIP WHEN THE
MONUMENT IS DESIGNATED. NATIONAL
MONUMENTS CAN ONLY BE DESIGNATED
ON PUBLICLY CONTROLLED LANDS. IN
DECEMBER OF 2023, THE BLM AND
THE FOREST SERVICE HOSTED A
SERIES OF LISTENING SESSIONS,
INCLUDING ONE WITH THE COMMUNITY
AND OVER 200 PEOPLE ATTENDED IF
YOU COULD, 75, THAT'D BE GREAT.
75 VOLUNTEERED TO GIVE PUBLIC
COMMENTS, AND OF THOSE WHO SPOKE
, 100 WERE IN FAVOR OF ADDING
MOORLACH LU█T TO THE MONUMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. APPRECIATE IT. THANK
YOU. NEXT WITNESS. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY. I
FIRST WANT TO THANK SENATOR DODD
FOR INTRODUCING, INTRODUCING
THIS JOINT RESOLUTION IN SUPPORT
OF THE EXPANSION OF BERRYESSA
SNOW MOUNTAIN NATIONAL MONUMENT
TO INCLUDE MORE LEOC. I ALSO
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THE
DESIGNATION OF MOORLACH APPLIES
ONLY TO PUBLIC LANDS AND WILL
ACTUALLY STRENGTHEN, NOT LIMIT,
RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES, AND
THIS IS ONE OF THE REASONS WE'VE
RECEIVED STRONG SUPPORT FROM THE
OHV OR OFF-HIGHWAY VEHICLE
COMMUNITY, AS, AS SENATOR DODD
SAID, MY NAME IS NICK JENSEN.
I'M THE CONSERVATION PROGRAM
DIRECTOR FOR THE NATIVE PLANT
SOCIETY. WE'RE A STATEWIDE
NONPROFIT WITH MORE THAN 13,000
MEMBERS, DEDICATED TO THE
PRESERVATION AND APPRECIATION OF
CALIFORNIA'S FLORA. THE EFFORT
TO PROTECT. I'D LIKE TO THINK
THAT THE EFFORT TO PROTECT
MOORLACH LAUP REPRESENTS THE
BEST IN MODERN CONSERVATION.
THIS INCLUDES THE RESPECT FOR
TRIBAL KNOWLEDGE AND INCLUSIVE
LAND MANAGEMENT COMMUNITIES
COMING TOGETHER WITH THE GOAL,
WITH WITH OF PROTECTING
BIODIVERSITY AMID A GLOBAL
EXTINCTION AND CLIMATE CRISIS.
CNPS HAS GREATLY, DEEPLY
GRATEFUL FOR THE YOCHA DEHE
WINTUN NATIONS LEADERSHIP IN
MAKING THIS REQUEST AND TO OUR
CONGRESSIONAL CHAMPIONS FOR
ASKING PRESIDENT BIDEN TO USE
THE POWERS OF THE ANTIQUITIES
ACT TO PROTECT MOLOKO YOK. NOW,
JUST A QUICK PERSONAL STORY. I
FIRST VISITED THIS AREA NEARLY
20 YEARS AGO. THAT DAY I WENT UP
TO THE RIDGE FOR THE SAME REASON
THAT HUNDREDS OF MEMBERS OF MY
ORGANIZATION CONTINUED TO VISIT
MELEKEOK, ITS RARE PLANTS. AS
YOU LIKELY KNOW, CALIFORNIA IS A
GLOBALLY IMPORTANT PLACE FOR
PLANT DIVERSITY, WITH THOUSANDS
OF SPECIES THAT OCCUR ONLY IN
THIS STATE, MANY OF WHICH ARE
RARE AND IMPERILED. MELEKEOK IS
A HOTSPOT OF PLANT DIVERSITY
WITHIN THE HOTSPOT THAT IS
CALIFORNIA, WITH AT LEAST 43
SPECIES OF RARE PLANTS TODAY.
THANKS TO THE WORK OF SO MANY,
MOMENTUM TOWARDS THE
CONSERVATION OF MALEKULA YOK IS
STRONG. MORE THAN 175,000 PEOPLE
HAVE SIGNED PETITIONS IN SUPPORT
OF THIS DESIGNATION. SECRETARY
HAALAND HAS VISITED THE AREA AND
MET WITH TRIBES AND LOCAL
LEADERS. AND IN DECEMBER, AS YOU
HEARD MY COLLEAGUE HEKIA SAY,
THE PUBLIC MEETING HOSTED BY BLM
AND FOREST SERVICE RECEIVED
THERE WAS MORE THAN 200 PEOPLE
IN ATTENDANCE AND 75 PEOPLE
SUPPORT AND SPOKE OUT IN SUPPORT
WITH ZERO OPPOSITION, WHICH IS
VERY RARE IN ANYTHING THESE
DAYS. RIGHT AND SO FOR ALL THOSE
REASONS, I ASK YOU TO STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE RESOLUTION TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY, BEFORE WE
PROCEED, I THINK WE NOW HAVE A
QUORUM. SO, ASSISTANT, IF YOU
COULD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL,
THAT'D BE GREAT. SENATORS. MEN
HERE, MEN HERE. SATO SIERRA
HERE. ALAN. DALLI. DALLI HERE.
EGGMAN. GROVE. HURTADO LAIRD.
LAIRD. HERE. LIMÓN PADILLA.
PADILLA. HERE. STERN. STERN HERE
. A QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED.
AND WITH THAT, WE'LL MOVE BACK
TO, XJR TEN, DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN THE ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL? THIS IS ME TWO
TESTIMONY, SO PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO YOUR NAME,
AFFILIATION, AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. THANK YOU, KIM DELFINO,
REPRESENTING I'M NOT SOMEONE
ELSE FROM DEFENDERS, IS COMING
UP. AUDUBON CALIFORNIA AND
MOJAVE DESERT LAND TRUST. THANK
YOU. AND THANK YOU. HI. SOPHIA
MURKOWSKI WITH DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
HI, AARON WOOLLEY, ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA, IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SANTIAGO
RODRIGUEZ WITH CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO
OTHER SUPPORT WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM, WE'LL MOVE ON TO ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. DO WE
HAVE ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NO ONE. DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS FINE BILL? I'M BEING
PEJORATIVE. OKAY, SEEING NO
OTHER WITNESSES, WE'LL BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS, SENATOR
LAIRD. THANK YOU. I WAS VERY
INVOLVED IN THE ORIGINAL
CREATION OF THE MONUMENT, AND
IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE I NOTED
THAT THE ORIGINAL MONUMENT WAS
303,780, 330,780 ACRES. AND THIS
ADDITION IS 3900 ACRES. SO IT'S
JUST OVER 1. SO IF I HAVE ANY
CHASTISING TO DO, I WOULD SAY TO
THE AUTHOR, THIS ISN'T ENOUGH,
BUT THIS IS GREAT BECAUSE IF YOU
HAVE BEEN THERE, IF YOU HAVE
HIKED IT OR BEEN THROUGH IT, IT
IS AN UNBELIEVABLE LANDSCAPE
THAT STRETCHES OVER A PERIOD.
AND I THINK THIS IS A GOOD
ADDITION. IT MEETS OUR 30 BY 30
GOALS AND AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME I WOULD MOVE THE
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU. ANY IT IS
APPROPRIATE. RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A
QUORUM. OKAY. WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR LAIRD. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE? OKAY. SEEING NONE, I
JUST WANTED TO ASK. THERE WERE
SOME TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THAT
THE COMMITTEE PROPOSED. AND
YOU'RE ACCEPTING THOSE
AMENDMENTS? YES. ALL RIGHT.
FANTASTIC. YES. AND THAT WAS
INCLUDED IN THE MOTION DO PASS
AS AMENDED. BUT I JUST WANT TO
HEAR FROM THE AUTHOR, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? YES, ABSOLUTELY.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
. FANTASTIC, WE HAVE A MOTION ON
COR TEN, Dð PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO, LET'S SEE. THIS WOULD BE DO
PASS IS AMENDED. SO ASSISTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS.
MINH. AYE MINH AYE. KADO. SATO.
AYE. ALAN DALI. EGGMAN. GROVE.
HURTADO LAIRD. AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE.
STERN. YEAH. FOR THE VOTE COUNT
IS FOUR ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE THAT
BILL ON CALL, AND WITH THAT,
WE'LL MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT BILL.
WHICH, FILE ITEM SIX IS SENATOR
ALLEN IN THE ROOM? NO. ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NO ONE, THEN I
GUESS WE'LL GO TO ME. THEN I
PASS THIS TO YOU. OH, YEAH.
SORRY. THANK YOU. SIR, WE'LL
MOVE ON TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WITH THAT. YEP AND SO, CONSENT
CALENDAR TODAY WE HAVE FIVE
BILLS ON PROPOSED CONSENT FILE,
ITEM NUMBER ONE, SB 1014 BY
SENATOR DODD. FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE, SB 1226 BY SENATOR CORTEZ
. FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR, SB 1425
BY SENATOR GONZALEZ, FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE, SB 1163 BY SENATOR
DALI. FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB
1029 BY SENATOR MINH. WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR DALI ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. AND SO WITH
QUORUM, WE'LL VOTE. ASSISTANT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
MINH. I MEAN, I SEE, I SEE, AYE.
ALAN DALI. YES DALI I EGGMAN
GROVE HURTADO LAIRD LAIRD I
LIMÓN PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE.
STERN OKAY. 123455. THE VOTE
COUNT IS FIVE ZERO, WE'LL LEAVE
THAT BILL ON CALL, AND THE NEXT
BILL UP, WILL BE ME, SB ONE, AM
I PRESENTING HERE? SA 12? OH, I
GOT THIS. OKAY, I GOT IT. I'M
JUST GETTING MY. WELCOME.
SENATOR MINH, IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO PRESENT YOUR BILL SCR 12, YOU
MAY PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. TODAY I'M
PRESENTING SGR 12, A RESOLUTION
TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
REVISE BANKRUPTCY RULES TO
ENSURE THAT THE OIL INDUSTRY
CANNOT USE EXISTING RULES TO
PUSH THEIR COSTS OF
DECOMMISSIONING OIL AND GAS
WELLS ONTO TAXPAYERS. STATE
TAXPAYERS, SPECIFICALLY. SEE, IN
2021, THE DISTRICT I REPRESENT,
THE 37TH SENATE DISTRICT,
EXPERIENCED A MAJOR OIL SPILL
OFF THE COAST OF HUNTINGTON
BEACH. OUR BEACHES WERE
BLACKENED, WILDLIFE WERE
SICKENED OR KILLED, AND LOCAL
SMALL BUSINESSES DEPENDENT ON
OUR COASTLINE SUFFERED MAJOR
ECONOMIC LOSSES, WHILE THOSE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE 2021 ORANGE
COUNTY OIL SPILL CONTINUE TO BE
HELD TO ACCOUNT FINANCIALLY
FARTHER UP THE COAST, OTHER
OPERATORS HAVE FOUND IT IN THEIR
BEST INTEREST TO DECLARE
BANKRUPTCY AND WALK AWAY FROM
DOZENS OF UNPLUGGED OIL WELLS
AND ASSOCIATED EQUIPMENT AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE BANKRUPTCIES
OF VENOCO AND RINCON ISLAND
LIMITED PARTNERS HAVE COST THE
STATE'S GENERAL FUND OVER $200
MILLION SO FAR, AND THAT NUMBER
IS EXPECTED TO GROW PERHAPS
EXPONENTIALLY. AND THAT DOES NOT
EVEN INCLUDE THE ONSHORE COSTS
TO ADDRESS ORPHAN WELLS
ESTIMATED TO BE IN THE BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS. THIS RESOLUTION IS A
COMMON SENSE, ONE THAT ASKS OUR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO MAKE SURE
THAT AN OIL WELL BANKRUPTCY WILL
NOT ADVERSELY AFFECT THE STATE'S
GENERAL FUND. I HAVE WITH ME
TODAY, SHERRY PEMBERTON FROM THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION, TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU FOR APPEARING TODAY.
MISS PEMBERTON. THAT IS MY ONLY
WITNESS. THANK YOU, MISS
PEMBERTON. AND YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. OH, WAIT. YOU GET FOUR
MINUTES BECAUSE THERE'S ONLY ONE
FOUR MINUTES IF YOU. OKAY IF YOU
NEED THEM. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
SHERRY PEMBERTON, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LANDS
COMMISSION AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
SDR 12, OUR COMMISSION IS THE
AGENCY WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
TAKING ON THE DECOMMISSIONING
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR TWO MAJOR
OFFSHORE OIL AND GAS OPERATIONS.
AFTER THE OPERATORS FILED FOR
BANKRUPTCY IN RECENT YEARS AND
WE'VE EXPERIENCED FIRSTHAND THE
ENORMOUS EFFECTS THAT THAT HAS
ON THE STATE AND THE TAXPAYERS.
AND WE'RE STILL WORKING THROUGH
THAT DECOMMISSIONING PROCESS AND
PLUGGING AND ABANDONING THE
WELLS AND ALL OF THE STEPS THAT
COME WITH THAT. WE HAVE NO
CONTROL AS A STATE OR A
COMMISSION OVER THE BANKRUPTCY
CODE. WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT
ENCOURAGING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO CHANGE THE
BANKRUPTCY CODE TO MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT, DIFFICULT FOR OIL AND
GAS OPERATORS TO FILE FOR
BANKRUPTCY AS A WAY TO, JETTISON
THEIR THEIR DECOMMISSIONING
RESPONSIBILITIES. I'LL ALSO ADD
THAT THESE RESPONSIBILITIES ARE
A PART OF THE LEASE AND WERE A
CONDITION THAT THE LESSEES
AGREED TO WHEN THEY WERE GIVEN A
LEASE TO REMOVE THESE MINERALS
FROM THE STATE'S WATERS. SO
REALLY STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION, AND I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. VERY
GOOD. THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY
ME TWOS IN FAVOR OF THE BILL IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL? COME ON UP.
STATE YOUR NAME, THE
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT AND
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
SANTIAGO RODRIGUEZ WITH
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS
IN SUPPORT. HI. CHRISTINA
SCARINGE WITH THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANKS ERIN. WALLY, ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA, IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THAT WAS VERY
ORDERLY. DO WE HAVE ANYBODY THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL AS A PRIMARY WITNESS,
THERE BEING NONE, IS THERE
ANYBODY WHO JUST WANTS TO COME
UP AND MEET YOU IN OPPOSITION? I
DON'T SEE ANYBODY SCRAMBLING. SO
WE'RE GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO
THE DAIS. ANYBODY ON THE DAIS
HAVE QUESTIONS, CONCERNS THAT
THEY'D LIKE TO EXPRESS? IF NOT,
WE CAN ENTERTAIN A MOTION. WE
HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL
BY SENATOR PADILLA. SO,
SECRETARY, CALL THE ROLL. OH,
DID YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. VERY. THAT WAS AN
EXCELLENT CLOSING. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT. GO AHEAD AND
CALL THE ROLL. THANK YOU. XJR
12, THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS
SENATORS MINH. I MEAN, I SEE.
ALAN DALLY. EGGMAN I'LL BE BACK.
GROVE DO YOU WANT TO VOTE ON
YOUR BILL FIRST? HER TITLE.
LAIRD LAIRD I LIMÓN I LIMÓN I
PADILLA. PADILLA I STERN. OKAY.
123444 OKAY, SO THAT BILL WILL
BE ON CALL. WE HAVE FOUR IN
FAVOR AND NONE OPPOSED, SO AT
THIS TIME, WE'RE GOING TO CALL
ON SENATOR ALLEN TO SCRAMBLE TO
THE ROOM SO THAT WE CAN FINISH
THE HEARING. SO WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE A RECESS UNTIL MR. ALLEN.
WANT ME TO CALL ROLL? YEAH, THAT
WOULD BE GOOD. WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND ADD ON THAT OTHER BILL. GO
AHEAD AND ADD ON. YEAH. LET'S.
YEAH. LET THE CALLS ON THOSE AND
TAKE ROLL OKAY. WE'RE LIFTING
THE CALLS ON ITEM FILE. ITEM
NUMBER TWO SJ R TI¾N. CURRENT
VOTE IS FOUR ZERO WITH CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR
ALLEN SEN, EGGMAN GROVE HURTADO
LIMÓN LIMÓN I. STERN. SENATOR
ALLEN, WE'RE VOTING ON COR TEN.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR ZERO.
THE MEASURE MOTION IS DUE. PASS
AS AMENDED. OUR SJ R TEN.
SENATOR ALLEN ALLEN I 5660. IT'S
ON. COOL OKAY. THAT MEASURE IS
SIX ZERO. IT'S ON CALL FOR NOW.
NEXT UP WE HAVE SENATOR ALLEN.
HE IS GOING TO BE INTRODUCING SB
1332. MR. ALLEN, WHEN YOU'RE
READY. WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MR. VICE CHAIR, I JUST WANT TO
START BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR ITS THOUGHTFUL WORK,
AS ALWAYS ON THIS MEASURE. AND
I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. MEMBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARK SYSTEM
IS DEAR TO MY HEART. I KNOW IT
IS. TO MANY. WE WERE JUST
TALKING ABOUT THE CHALLENGES AT
MALAKOFF DIGGINS THE OTHER DAY
IN THE IN THE BUDGET SUB, WHERE
SENATOR DARLING AND I SERVE.
THESE ARE SPECIAL PLACES, THEY
OFFER OPPORTUNITIES TO GET
OUTSIDE, EXPLORE NATURE, VISIT
HISTORICAL LANDMARKS, EACH OF
OUR STATE PARKS REPRESENT A
PROMISE TO OUR CHILDREN AND
FUTURE GENERATIONS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO PRESERVE THE AREA SO
THAT THEY, TOO, CAN ENJOY IT AS
WE DO. THERE ARE PLACES THAT WE
HAVE SET ASIDE AS A STATE, FOR,
FOR, AND MARKED WITH A CERTAIN
DEGREE OF SPECIALNESS, BUT YOU
KNOW, WHILE WE'VE, WE'VE I WILL
SAY, I MEAN, I'M KIND OF SHOCKED
SOMETIMES BY THE STATE OF
DISREPAIR IN A LOT OF OUR STATE
PARKS. AND, YOU KNOW, JUST LAST
WEEK, OUR STATE PARKS DIRECTOR,
QUINTERO, REFERENCED THEIR
BILLION DOLLAR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG AS A GENERAL
FUND. REVENUE HAS NOT KEPT PACE
WITH THE NEEDS FOR YEARS, FOR
THE FIRST, FOR THE I THINK FOR
THE LAST FIVE YEARS OR SO, MANY
OF YOU KNOW, I'VE BEEN WORKING
ON A CLIMATE AND NATURAL
RESOURCES BOND TO FUND IMPORTANT
MITIGATION AND RESTORATION WORK,
INCLUDING WITHIN OUR PARKS. AND
I'VE JUST BECOME REALLY ACUTELY
AWARE OF HOW IMPORTANT AND
NEEDED THE FUNDING IS, CERTAINLY
BOND FUNDING CAN BE USED TO
ACQUIRE LANDS. IT CAN'T BE USED
FOR STEWARDSHIP AND MAINTENANCE.
AND OF COURSE, THE BONDS NEEDED
FOR LOTS OF OTHER THINGS AS
WELL. SO THIS BILL SEEKS TO TAKE
A NOVEL APPROACH TO ADDRESSING
THIS CHRONIC FUNDING SHORTFALL.
IT ESTABLISHES A CONSERVATION
STEWARDSHIP ENDOWMENT FUND TO
ACCEPT PRIVATE DONATIONS AND
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS. TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE, YOU KNOW, THE
STATE'S WILLING TO PROVIDE THE
MONEY WILL BE INVESTED WITH THE
GOAL OF ACHIEVING A SUFFICIENT
BALANCE TO GENERATE ONGOING IN
EARNINGS TO COVER THE ANNUAL
STEWARDSHIP AND MAINTENANCE
COSTS OF PARK LANDS. AND THE
IDEA HERE IS THAT IT WILL
PROVIDE A MECHANISM TO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDING IMPORTANT BENEFITS
THROUGH OUR STATE PARK SYSTEM
FOR GENERATIONS TO COME. AND
WITH ME HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
IS ISABELLA GONZALEZ PORTER FROM
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY. AND I DO
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THIS. ALL RIGHT. IF
THE WITNESS WILL COME FORWARD,
YOU HAVE A TOTAL OF FOUR MINUTES
IF YOU NEED THEM, LESS IF YOU
DON'T GOT IT. GOOD AFTERNOON.
NOON VICE CHAIR AND SENATORS
ISABELLA GONZALEZ, POTTER WITH
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY. WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATOR
ALLEN'S SB 1332. TNC IS A
SCIENCE BASED ORGANIZATION THAT
WORKS WORLDWIDE TO DELIVER
CONSERVATION SOLUTIONS THAT
BENEFIT BOTH PEOPLE AND NATURE.
CALIFORNIA'S MORE THAN 280 STATE
PARKS ARE RICH IN BIODIVERSITY,
SUPPORT HEALTHY AND RESILIENT
ECOSYSTEMS, AND OFFER MANY
IMPORTANT BENEFITS TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS. STATE PARKS
PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS,
INCLUDING OUTDOOR RECREATION,
WILDLIFE HABITAT, CLIMATE CHANGE
MITIGATION, WATER AND AIR
PURIFICATION, AND MORE. AS SUCH,
STATE PARKS PLAY A CRUCIAL ROLE
IN ACHIEVING CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE GOALS AND SEVERAL HIGH
PRIORITY STATE INITIATIVES,
INCLUDING THE 30 BY 30
INITIATIVE. THE OUTDOORS,
OUTDOORS FOR ALL INITIATIVE, AND
THE WATER SUPPLY STRATEGY, AMONG
OTHERS. WHILE CALIFORNIA HAS
MADE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS TO
PROTECT AND CONSERVE THESE LANDS
, DEDICATED RESOURCES FOR
STEWARDSHIP AND MANAGEMENT ARE
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT THEY
REMAIN HEALTHY LANDSCAPES AND
CONTINUE TO BENEFIT ALL
CALIFORNIANS. AS SENATOR ALLEN
WAS JUST ARTICULATING, A GENERAL
OBLIGATION BOND FUNDING CAN BE
USED TO ACQUIRE AND PROTECT
THESE LANDS. HOWEVER,
STEWARDSHIP AND MANAGEMENT
ACTIVITIES ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
BOND FUNDING. THE LACK OF
FUNDING FOR MAINTENANCE AND
STEWARDSHIP HAS RESULTED IN A
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BACKLOG
TOTALING MORE THAN $1 BILLION
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS
ALONE. SO AS THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE INTENSIFY,
MANAGEMENT AND STEWARDSHIP OF
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS AND
CONSERVATION LANDS WILL BECOME
INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT, HE
ALREADY ARTICULATED THAT IT
WOULD ESTABLISH THE CONSERVATION
STEWARDSHIP ENDOWMENT FUND AND
AS SUCH, SB 1332 WILL ENSURE
THAT OUR STATE PARKS CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE IMPORTANT BENEFITS FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. WE THANK YOU.
GREAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AT
THIS TIME, THOSE THAT WISH TO
EXPRESS THEIR ENTHUSIASM FOR
THIS BILL CAN COME TO THE MIC
STATE. SO WITH YOUR NAME, THE
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT AND
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. GOOD
AFTERNOON, TASHA NEWMAN ON
BEHALF OF BOLSA, BOLSA CHICA
LAND TRUST IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON CAÑADA ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA TROUT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. SANTIAGO RODRIGUEZ
WITH CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
VOTERS IN SUPPORT. GREAT. NOW
THERE. NOW IS A TIME FOR ANYBODY
WHO MIGHT BE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL TO COME UP IF THEY
WANT TO BE A PRIMARY WITNESS, WE
CAN GIVE THEM A COUPLE OF THREE
MINUTES. SO COME ON UP IF THAT'S
WHAT YOU WANT TO DO. SEEING AS
NOBODY IS COMING TO THE MIC,
ANYBODY JUST WANT TO COME UP AND
SAY I OPPOSE AND SIT DOWN,
THAT'S FINE. NO NO. OKAY. WE'RE
GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
DAIS FOR A DISCUSSION. MR. JOHN
LAIRD, THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
CHAIR. I HAD A FEW QUESTIONS AND
THEN A COMMENT. THE THE,
ANALYSIS SAYS YOU'RE TAKING AN
AMENDMENT, BUT IT ALSO SAYS THE
BILL IS A WORK IN PROGRESS AND
SUGGESTS AN EXPENDITURE PLAN AND
AN ENDOWMENT FUND REPORT. AND
STAKEHOLDER OUTREACH. WAS ANY OF
THAT INCLUDED IN THE AMENDMENT
THAT WAS TAKEN, OR IS THAT A
SUGGESTION PAST THE AMENDMENT?
OH, I WILLING TO ACCEPT THOSE
THOSE SUGGESTIONS. I DON'T KNOW
IF WE FORMALLY HAVE. I MAYBE I
SHOULD ADD SO I'M CERTAINLY
WILLING TO ACCEPT THOSE
SUGGESTIONS. I READ THAT AND
THOUGHT IT WAS REASONABLE, BUT I
DON'T KNOW THAT THEY'VE BEEN
DRAWN OUT IN, IN OUR WE'RE SO
INSTRUCTED NOT TO NEGOTIATE FROM
THE DÍAS. SO IF YOU DON'T HAVE
THE AMENDMENTS, IT'S LIKE IT'S
CLEAR THAT THE ANALYSIS SAYS
THOSE WOULD BE NICE. AND YEAH,
YOU SHOULD WORK. THE OTHER
QUESTION I HAD IS, IS I HAD
ATTEMPTED TO DO, A VEHICLE
LICENSE FEE INCREASE IN EXCHANGE
FOR ANYBODY WITH A CALIFORNIA
LICENSE COULD GET IN FREE TO A
STATE PARK. AND IT DIDN'T WORK,
AND IT WENT TO THE VOTERS. AND
THEN THE GREAT RECESSION
HAPPENED IN BETWEEN. SO IT
DIDN'T PASS. THERE WAS A $60
MILLION ANNUAL INCREASE TO PARKS
IN CONJUNCTION WITH WITH THE OHV
PIECE OF THE THAT WAS MORE
GENERAL IN THE TRANSPORTATION
BOND AND PARKS CALIFORNIA, WHICH
WAS CREATED OUT OF THE REFORMS,
THE ANALYSIS SAYS IS UP TO 5
MILLION A YEAR. THIS DOESN'T
DIVERT ANYTHING AWAY FROM THESE
EFFORTS, DOES IT? BECAUSE THE 5
MILLION A YEAR IS PRIVATE
CONTRIBUTIONS PRIMARILY. SO THIS
ISN'T GOING TO DIVERT IT FROM
FROM WHAT'S HAPPENED? NO, I
MEAN, I DO THINK THAT, IF THIS
PROCEEDS, WE WILL PROBABLY GOING
TO WANT TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW THEY INTERACT, BUT BUT
THEY'RE, THEY'RE THEY'RE
SEPARATE AND IT DOESN'T IT
DOESN'T DIVERT. AND IT SAYS THAT
THERE'D BE GOVERNMENT MONEY TO
THIS, TO CREATE THE ENDOWMENT,
TO CREATE INTEREST, TO GO TO
PARKS. BUT THERE'S NO MONEY IN
THIS BILL AT THIS POINT, GIVEN
THE YEAR THAT WE'RE IN. RIGHT.
AND I THINK WE ANTICIPATE, GIVEN
THE CURRENT CIRCUMSTANCES, THAT
WE WOULD NEED TO FRONT FILL IT
WITH, WITH PHILANTHROPIC WORK. I
MEAN, I THINK THAT'S THAT'S THE
FOCUS RIGHT NOW. BUT WE
CERTAINLY DIDN'T WANT TO
PRECLUDE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
GENERAL FUND TO PUT MONEY INTO
IT IN THE FUTURE, YOU KNOW,
DURING UP UPTURN. BUT THE IDEA
IS, IS TO HAVE AN ENDOWMENT
WHERE IT'S THE INTEREST ANNUALLY
THAT GOES TO PARKS, NOT GOING
INTO THE CORPUS. RIGHT. YEAH.
THAT'S RIGHT. THAT'S RIGHT.
WE'RE WE'RE ENGAGING IN I MEAN,
I THINK THEY'RE SOMEWHAT
DIFFERENT VISIONS AS TO HOW TO
STRUCTURE IT, BUT BUT THAT'S
RIGHT. THAT'S WELL, I SEE SOME
AND I WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE NATIONAL WILDLIFE WHATEVER
KNIFE FOUNDATION IN MY PRIOR
THING. AND THAT WAS DESIGNED TO
GET PRIVATE DONATIONS TO HELP
WITH PUBLIC, PROJECTS. I THINK
MY ONLY CONCERN IS THAT YOU MAKE
SURE THAT SEEKING PRIVATE
PHILANTHROPY DOESN'T DIVERT THE
PRIVATE PHILANTHROPY THAT'S
GOING TO PARKS, CALIFORNIA.
YEAH, BUT, I APPLAUD YOU FOR
THIS EFFORT. IT DOES NEED SOME
WORK, BUT I AM WILLING TO MOVE
THE BILL. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
ANYBODY ELSE COMMENTS?
QUESTIONS? WE HAVE A MOTION TO
MOVE THE BILL. AND THIS IS A Dð
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO
APPROPRIATIONS. AND YOU DID SAY
YOU WERE TAKING COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS, CORRECT? OKAY. MR.
SECRETARY, YOU WANT TO CALL THE
ROLL? OH, YOU WANT TO DO YOUR
CLOSING? I'M SORRY. NO, I
APPRECIATE APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS AND ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. RESPECTFULLY, I
KEEP FORGETTING THAT PART. THANK
YOU. YOU KNOW, SO WHAT HAPPENS
IN YOUR PART TIME? GO AHEAD AND
CALL THE ROLL, PLEASE. OKAY.
YOU'RE DOING GREAT, MR. CHAIR,
FOR SB 1332, SENATORS MINH SATO,
I CELADO I ALLEN I ALLEN I DALI
I DALI I EGGMAN GROVE HURTADO
HURTADO I LAIRD. LAIRD I LIMÓN
LIMÓN I PADILLA PADILLA I STERN.
THANK YOU. MEMBERS. THANK YOU.
GOOD ALL RIGHT. THAT MEASURE HAS
SIX VOTES AND WE'LL LEAVE IT ON
CALL SEVEN VOTES AND WE'LL LEAVE
IT ON CALL. SO AT THIS TIME,
WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE CALL ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR TO GET
EVERYBODY ADDED ON THAT WANTS
TO. AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE AT
THIS TIME FOR OTHER MEMBERS THAT
ARE ON THIS COMMITTEE AND WANT
TO BE ADDED ON TO THE WALK WITH
PURPOSE DOWN THE HALLWAYS TO GET
HERE SO THAT WE CAN CONCLUDE THE
MEETING. JUST IN TIME FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FILE ITEM
NUMBER SB 1014 FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE 1226 FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
1425 FILE. ITEM NUMBER 511 SB
1163 FILE. ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB
1029. CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE ZERO,
WITH CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATOR ALLEN ALLEN AYE.
EGGMAN GROVE HURTADO HURTADO
VÚI. LIMÓN. LIMÓN AYE. STERN AND
STERN. AYE. OKAY, SO ITEM ONE I
DIDN'T HEAR YOU CALLED IT FILE
ITEM ONE. THIS IS SB 1014 ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AS WELL. AND
OKAY, SO. THE CURRENT NUMBER IS
NINE ZERO. SO IT'S STILL ON
CALL. ALL RIGHT. SO THE CURRENT
VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
NINE ZERO. WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE
IT ON CALL FOR THE ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THAT ARE SCRAMBLING DOWN
FROM THEIR OFFICES TO GET HERE
TO VOTE. I I DON'T THINK YES.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO LIFT
THE CALL ON CER TEN FOR THE
MEMBERS THAT NEED TO ADD ON. CER
TEN THE CURRENT MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED. THE CURRENT
VOTE IS SIX ZERO WITH CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR
DALLI, EGGMAN GROVE. HURTADO.
HURTADO. AYE. STERN OAN. STERN.
AYE. EIGHT ZERO SO THAT MEASURE
IS EIGHT ZERO. AND WE'LL LEAVE
THAT ON CALL FOR MEMBERS TO ADD
ON. WE'LL TAKE A RECESS OR WHAT?
NO DELYLAH ITEM NUMBER.
THURMOND. YEAH, I COULD DO MR.
HERE WE DO, WE CAN DO. ALL RIGHT
, WE'RE GOING TO GO TO FILE ITEM
EIGHT, WHICH IS SCR 12 MIN, AND
ADD ON FOR THOSE THAT MISSED THE
VOTE. CURRENT VOTE IS Dð. THE
MOTION IS Dð PASS IN THE CURRENT
VOTE IS FOUR ZERO, WITH CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATOR CIARDO.
SENATOR. ALAN. ALAN. AYE EGGMAN
GROVE. HURTADO. HURTADO. AYE.
STERN AND STERN. AYE SO SEVEN
ZERO ON GOALS. SEVEN, THAT VOTE
IS SEVEN ZERO. WE'LL STILL LEAVE
IT ON CALL, MEMBERS. IF YOU
COULD COME BACK AND CONCLUDE
VOTING, THAT'D BE GREAT. ALL
RIGHT, LAST BILL, 1332. SANDRA,
WE COULD DO 1332. OKAY, WE'LL
DO, GO BACK TO FILE ITEM. I'M
SORRY. WE'LL GO BACK TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER. WHAT ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT? HE'S PROBABLY.
AND I NEED
.
OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX, SB 1332 IS
NOT. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATE ACTIONS.
I THINK THE MOTION CAME FROM
SENATOR LAIRD. ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AND THE CURRENT
VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO WITH VICE
CHAIR VOTING. AYE. SENATOR MIN
AYE. MIN AYE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN.
AYE. GROVE STERN. STERN. AYE
EGGMAN. AYE. YEAH. OKAY SO. 123,
WE'RE ZERO. YEAH. TEN. ZERO.
THAT VOTE IS THAT VOTE IS TEN
ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT. NO, I
DON'T SHE JUST SAID GROVE'S NOT
COMING. OKAY OKAY, THEN WE CAN.
THE BILL IS OUT. OKAY. OKAY.
WE'LL GO BACK TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO, SCR TEN BY SENATOR
DODD. THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, THE MOTION FROM SENATOR
LAIRD. ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. CURRENT VOTE IS EIGHT
ZERO WITH CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING. AYE, SENATOR. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN. AYE OKAY. THAT VOTE IS
NINE ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT,
WE'LL GO NOW TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
NUMBER EIGHT BY SENATOR MINH COR
12, THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS.
ASSISTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CURRENT VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO WITH
CHAIR VOTING AYE AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO. SENATOR. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN. AYE OKAY. SO EIGHT.
RIGHT? THAT BILL IS OUT. EIGHT
ZERO. FINALLY, WE'LL GO TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. AND THE
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR FILE.
ITEM NUMBER ONE, SB 1014, FILE.
ITEM NUMBER THREE, SB 1226 FILE.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR, SB 1425 FILE.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE, SB 1163, AND
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN, SB 1029.
CURRENT VOTE IS NINE ZERO, WITH
BOTH CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATOR EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE
OKAY, THAT'S TEN HOURS, THAT THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT TEN
ZERO. AND THANK YOU, EVERYONE
FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION. THAT CONCLUDES THE
AGENDA. SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES
AND WATER COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED.